when an actor leaves a hit show it can
either be a blessing or a curse
sometimes right outs are worked into a
show very nicely like with the revolving
door on Grey's Anatomy that only adds to
the drama factor in other cases though a
character is so essential that their
disappearance downright dooms the series
especially when they're replaced by
someone who doesn't have the same appeal
as the original star duh here are a few
TV shows that just couldn't recover from
the loss and replacement of a major cast
member the office
Steve Carell was a well-known comic
force from The Daily Show and anchorman
before he got his biggest break with the
small screen comedy series the office
the show was an American adaptation of
the Ricky Gervais BBC sitcom of the same
name and became wildly popular with
audiences I've made you what you are and
I'll get nothing back
Corrales film career started to take off
shortly thereafter with starring roles
in movies like the 40 year old virgin
little miss sunshine and Crazy Stupid
Love elevating him to household name
status so in 2013 when Carroll's
contract with the office was up he opted
to walk away from the series even though
it was still a critical and rating set
for NBC the awkward lovelorn michael
scott finally found love with HR
director holly and they moved away to
colorado
but dunder mifflin still needed a boss
and that came in the form of oily
unsettling Robert California CEO of its
parent company saber Wow
I will not be blackmailed by some
ineffectual privilege defeats soft
debutante and it was all downhill from
there the show's critical favour and
viewership numbers took a nosedive and
the series finally came to a close after
two Carell three seasons the x-files for
its first six seasons the x-files was a
huge hit for Fox and made its on-screen
pair of paranormal investigators
international stars but prior to the
start of the series seventh season David
Duchovny sued the network claiming that
it had sold rights to reruns of the show
at a discount to its own affiliates and
cheated the stars out of profits while
the lawsuit was eventually settled it
was filed right when the company was
negotiating working on future seasons of
the show and neither he nor Fox were
keen to continue working together
so a deal was reached the company's
character Fox Mulder would mysteriously
disappear at the end of season seven and
would only appear in a handful of
episodes in season eight
but Gillian Anderson's agent Scully
still needed someone to work with in his
absence so producers auditioned dozens
of actors and eventually settled on
Robert Patrick to come in as FBI agent
John Doggett another actress was also
hired in case Anderson decided to leave
the show after her contract into two it
didn't matter much though because
without the company in his regular role
viewers tuned out she saved me as
difficult and as frustrating as it's
been sometimes your goddamn strict
rationalism and science was saved me a
thousand times over eight simple rules
for dating my teenage daughter this ABC
sitcom was forced to reformat after the
unexpected death of its star 8 simple
rules
built around TV legend John Ritter who
starred is a cranky suburban dad
desperately trying to rein in his wild
teenage children filming had just begun
on the second season of the series when
Ritter fell ill on the set and sought
medical treatment he died later that day
of a heart defect that had never been
diagnosed ABC announced that the show
would go on and it did with some
necessary changes no longer a show about
a cranky dad it became one about a
family trying to pick up the pieces
after the death of its patriarch to new
stars joined the cast to fill the void
left by Ritter cousin CJ and Grandpa Jim
but without Ritter the show only lasted
another season before being shelved for
good Blue's Clues
actor musician Steve Burns beat out
roughly 1,000 other actors in 1996 for
the only human role one Blue's Clues
Nickelodeon's interactive animation
live-action hybrid show for preschoolers
Burns played the Striped sure did the
host and owner of the cartoon dog named
blue he talked directly to the young
viewers at home urging them to help
solve each episodes Riddler mystery by
yelling things at their screens in 2002
after about 100 episodes Burns decided
it was time to leave the series he
wanted to take on other roles as well as
perform music Nickelodeon hired actor
donovan patton to be the new host of
Blue's Clues
playing Steve's younger brother Joe so
is that Trump tides are confused the
show's very young viewers Steve
carefully explained that he was leaving
for college and Cho would be looking
after blue Patton as Joe proved to be
the gentle and affable host Blue's Clues
needed but he just couldn't replace
someone so closely associated with the
role - an army of toddlers after around
50 episodes with Patton as Joe blues
Blues was canceled scrubs
this comedy about medical interns
desperately trying to figure out what
they were doing as they worked in a
hospital was a critically acclaimed Emmy
nominated hits over its first few
seasons on NBC the network dropped the
show after seven seasons only to see ABC
pick it up the show's writers and cast
prepared a true series finale at the end
of the year only for ABC to unexpectedly
renew the series again
in 9 but starred Zach Braff the focus of
the show as young dr. John Dorian was
ready to move on to other things awkward
oh good god so the show was retooled and
rebooted no longer taking place at a
teaching hospital but at a medical
school dr. Cox and dr. Turk were now
teachers instead of active surgeons I'm
just back to teach some classes
replacing Braff as the center of the
show and narrator was dr. Lucy Bennett
but the big changes were too much to
take and the ninth season of scrubs was
also its last Spin City Michael J Fox
returned a regular series television for
the first time since the end of family
ties with Spin City on the ABC sitcom he
played Mike Flaherty a wheeler-dealer
for a New York City deputy mayor two
years later Fox announced that he had
been battling Parkinson's disease and
left the show to spend more time raising
funds for research on the disease
replacing him as deputy mayor was a guy
named Charlie Crawford portrayed by
Charlie Sheen with Fox out the show
became more of a romantic comedy
surrounding Sheen and Heather Locklear's
characters but viewership tanked shortly
after the replacement so ABC cut the
cord on Spin City can't kiss you guys
aren't ready for that yet but your kids
are gonna love it designing women' Delta
Burke had not been happy on the set of
designing women for years she even
claimed that a producer routinely
screamed at cast members and told them
they were expendable and criticized
Burke when she gained weight are you
serious CBS grew so tired of Burke
publicly trashing the show's producers
and the network in the press that they
fired her from the show and co-star Jean
smart followed her out the door shortly
thereafter every time I look over at the
soap I kind of miss seeing her that
meant that designing women had lost half
its main cast but the show was still a
ratings draw so the network brought in
some replacements now I know that all of
our nerves are a little bit jangling
cause of the silly old money situation
but you know what we got to do we got to
look for the light Julia Duffy arrived
as Suzanne's cousin and Jan hooks came
in as Carlene Charlene's sister despite
ratings on par with previous years CBS
fired Duffy after her sole season on the
series and replaced her Judith Ivey as a
rich Texan widow named BJ Poteet it
didn't do much good because CBS moved
the show to Friday nights where it
slipped into ratings oblivion and then
cancellation and that is the night the
lights went out in Georgia that 70s show
after seven seasons of riding on a high
ratings wise at least two of that 70
shows main stars decided to step away
from the series Topher Grace decided to
leave the show in order to more fiercely
pursue his blossoming film career and
was written out of the eighth season
altogether meanwhile Ashton Kutcher
decided his time in the bell-bottoms was
done - but did appear for a few of
season eights early episodes to replace
two very big holes in the cast producers
hired MADtv veteran Josh Meyers his
character Randy joins Hyde's record
store grooves and has a brief
relationship with Donna
but Randy didn't have much time to mesh
with the ensemble because the decimated
cast led to diminish popularity for the
show and it was ultimately canned at the
end of the season you have the right to
remain community even though community
never had a huge audience during its
five-year run on NBC it was still
critically acclaimed comedy with a
passionate cult following five seasons
was ultimately NBC's limit but Internet
giant Yahoo stepped in a renewed
community for a sixth season intending
to position the comedy is a premiere
offering on its streaming service Yahoo
screen original regulars Joel McHale
Gillian Jacobs Danny Pudi
Ken John and Alison Brie followed the
series to Yahoo but the show had already
been losing cast members left and right
and kept losing them as a transition to
streaming Chevy Chase Donald Glover and
event Nicole Brown were not part of the
regular cast of community's sixth season
new actors were added including Keith
David and paget Brewster but it just
didn't work out and there was no seventh
season of community on Yahoo scream or
anywhere not enough people tuned in and
the show didn't generate as much
advertising revenue as yeah
note the revenue was so small that it
effectively led to the complete shutdown
of the Yahoo scream show may be canceled
and moved to the Internet where it turns
out tens of millions were watching the
whole time may not matter if a
commercial bandwidth disclaimer gag
which may descend into vain Chuck Lorre
s grant by narcissistic creator thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]